I stand before you today to say these
words I announce my candidacy for
president of the United States of
America
nearly a dozen Democrats are already
running for president so highlight so
far include an interview about
immigration live stream from a dental
chair a former Harvard professor popping
a beer like just plain folks on New
Year's Eve and a draconian former
prosecutor pledging her allegiance to
Wakanda paid for by Kamala Harris
Democrats are tripping over each other
to pitch Medicare for all free college
for all jobs for all and laying taxes on
wealth as well as income and then
there's Howard Schultz I think the
Democrats need a little bit less
caffeine right now the former CEO of
Starbucks announced that he's
considering a run for president as a
centrist independent he says that the
national debt threatens economic growth
that we shouldn't demonize successful
entrepreneurs and that the government
can't be all things to all people
both parties are consistently not doing
what's necessary on behalf of the
American people and aren't engaged every
single day in revenge politics that
brought public hate contempt and
character assassination from every
conceivable angle
[Music]
it's not just anti-globalist lefties on
the attack the New York Times op-ed page
says he's narcissistic delusional and
fanatical his potential run his critics
claim would be nothing short of reckless
idiocy
Schultz's belief that neither major
party represents America very well is
widely shared a plurality of Americans
don't identify with either party and
nearly three-quarters of us think the
country is headed in the wrong direction
which helps to explain why neither
Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump when a
majority of the popular vote in 2016 the
two-party duopoly and its supporters in
the media understand how widely disliked
they are which is why they want to
kneecap anyone who isn't on Team writer
team blue you don't have to agree with
Schultz to understand that having more
ideas and more voices at the table at
this point in the election cycle is a
good thing especially when you consider
the alternatives Democrats fear people
such as Schultz because they think he'll
drain votes from whoever their nominee
ends up being giving Trump a path to
re-election but that's actually a faulty
analysis former Republican Congressman
John Anderson was blamed for pulling
votes from Jimmy Carter in 1980 but
almost half of his supporters would have
gone with Ronald Reagan as their second
choice in 1992 the GOP fingered Ross
Perot as a political saboteur but in
fact the 19 percent of Americans have
pulled the lever for the Texas
billionaire were equally split between
Bush and Clinton as their fallback the
end of the day you don't necessarily
need the choice of 23 underwhelming
spray do for 18 different pairs of
sneakers when children are hungry if
variety an armpit aroma isn't its thing
I'd like to believe that the Vermont
socialists still believes we should have
more choices at the ballot box right now
there are more forms of hepatitis than
viable political parties in America so
it's kind of fitting that the former CEO
of a company that introduced infinite
choice and coffee drinks is now being
dragged for threatening to expand the
political spectrum all the way from 8
see if American politics can't even
stand the possibility of an independent
candidate who praises capitalism opposes
massive tax increases and wants to cut
the federal debt
we're already screwed in 2020
[Music]